our next reward is a new one the Academy
has added the past year
audiences of gasped at in fright at
several terrifying films that made our
flesh crawl on my mouth crawl as a case
may be 2% that award are the
unforgettable stars of two classic
movies the House of Wax and Planet of
the Apes and
when lon chaney
twisted and tortured himself into a
series of roles that established him as
the man of a thousand faces makeup
artists have been able to help the least
of us seem to be more than we are and
the best of us yes yes that's true yes
now considered gentle Boris Karloff is
the definitive movie monster from
Frankenstein Dustin Hoffman 100 B 20
year-old little big man John who it's
painfully hideous elephant dolls Lordan
stroke has Hunchback of Notre Dame
the young Orson Welles as the aging
citizen came
kirk douglas disguised in a list of
every messenger the battered raging
bull' of robert de niro the buttered
Tony Curtis and Jack Lemmon is
long
ray Bolger Jack Haley Margaret Hamilton
all in The Wizard of Oz
the tendons
the greatest show alone in Jimmy Stewart
behind clouds make up one of the seven
faces of dr. Lao lows only Randall wore
Shirley MacLaine became a convincing
geisha
Linda Blair possessed and The Exorcist
in rocky Sylvester Stallone's face
certainly was the transformation if
they'd ever go to Mommy Dearest a human
into a werewolf in the howling and
forever the poetic landscape of Beauty
the face of gobble these imaginative won
workers who design and apply the makeup
we wear
well henceforth be honored with their
own Oscars
not only for the greatest makeups or the
macabre but also for the subtle delicacy
of shading and highlighting features an
art that goes back to the ancient
Egyptians and which our makeup artists
continue to improve this year the
Academy has nominated two artists for
their contributions and those nominees
are Werewolf in London Stan Winston for
heart beats Vincent will you reveal the
winner no please you do it
openings always make me shaky the winner
is Rick Baker for an American
first of all I'd like to thank the
Academy for treating this new category
and I'm very proud to be the first
winner
thank john landis and george fotion for
making the film david Naughton and
griffin dunne for the cooperation i'd
like to thank my prude bez wick tom
Hester Steve Johnson Sean McEnroe Bill
sturgeon Kevin Brennan and Lane Baker
for working so hard and in such a great
job I'd like to thank my parents stores
and Ralph Baker for the love and support
and last but not least I'd like to thank
a man who's been a real inspiration to
me dick Smith for all the dick is
contributed to the art of makeup
where all the deepest contributed to the
art of makeup you deserve an Academy
Award more than any makeup artist I know
thank you